اصيب مستوطن اسرائيليون بجروح وصفت
بالخطيره اثر اطلاق النار عليه على مدخل
مستوطنه حرمش الواقعه غرب يعبد شمال الضفه
الغربيه وذكرت القناه الثانيه عشره
الاسرائيليه ان المصابه تعرض لاطلاق نار
من سياره عابره كما افاد مراسل الجزيره
بان قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ورعت الى
مكان العمليه وبدات في حمله مطارده
لاقتفاء اثر مطلق النار
ينضم الينا من القدس مراسل الجزيره الياس
كرام الياس ضعنا في اخر التطورات
العمليه بالفعل وقعت على مدخل مستوطنه
خرميش الواقعه الى الغربي من مدينه يعبد
في شمال الضفه الغربيه المحتله والتقديرات
الاوليه بان عمليه اطلاق النار تمت من
داخل سياره عابره باتجاه سياره كان
يستقلها احد المستوطنين على مدخل
مستوطنه حرمش وهي مستوطنه صغيره تقع الى
الشمال الغربي من الضفه الغربيه المحتله
الاسعاف الاسرائيلي هرع الى المكان
بالاضافه الى الفرق الطبيه التابعه لقوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وقدموا العلاج الاولي
للمستوطن الذي وصفت جروحه بانها بالغه
الخطوره من ثم نقل هناك على عجل من هناك
على عجل الى مستشفى هلال ياف في مدينه
الخضيره في داخل اسرائيل لمواصله العلاج
الجيش جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي فرض طوقا
امنيا كبيرا في المناطق القريبه من
مستوطنه حرميش واقام
يبدو حواجز طياره على عدد من القرى
القريبه من موقع العمليه في محاوله
لاكتفاء اثر منفذها او منفذيها عاده ما
تعتقد قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي عندما تتم
عمليه اطلاق النار من داخل سياره عابره
فهي ترجح بان اثنين على الاقل من
الفلسطينيون من الفلسطينيين يقفون وراء
هذه العمليه احدهم يقود السياره والثاني
يقوم باطلاق النار باتجاه الهدف الذي
يريده وهذه العمليه تاتي في خضم عمليات
دهن واعتقالات مستمره من جانب قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي التي تستهدف خلايا
المقاومه الفلسطينيه في شمال الضفه
الغربيه المحتله في تحديدا في مخيم جنين
ومناطق جنين وكذلك في نابلس والمناطق
المجاوره لها ولكن رغم كل هذه المحاولات
والحملات العسكريه وعمليات الدهم
والاعتقال والقتل لا يبدو ان قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيليه قادره
وقف هذه العمليات الفلسطينيه التي تتكرر
بين الحين والاخر ومن الواضح بان الخلايا
الفلسطينيه ما زالت قادره على العمل وعلى
استهداف قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
واستهداف المستوطنين الذين يسلكون الطرق
الفلسطينيه وايضا الطرق الالتفافيه التي
اقيمت على اراضي الفلسطينيين المصادره
والتي تخدم تحديدا هذه المستوطنات النائيه
هذه الخلايا ما زالت تعمل رغم كل الجهد
العسكري الاسرائيلي المبذول في الضفه
الغربيه المحتله وما زالت قادره على تسديد
اصابات سواء كان ذلك في صفوف المستوطنين
او في صفوف قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ومن
الملاحظ في الاسابيع الاخيره بان هذه
الخلايا باتت تحول هذه الطرق الالتفافيه
التي يسلكها
المستوطنون الى اماكننا لاصطيادهم والى
استهدافهم كما ان بعض المستوطنات
الاسرائيليه النائيه القريبه من جنين
وكذلك تلك البلدات الاسرائيليه الواقعه
داخل الخط الاخضر والقريبه منه باتت هدفا
لهذه الخلايا التي تقوم باطلاق انار من
رشاشات خفيفه باتجاه المستوطنات
الاسرائيليه وكذلك باتجاه البلدات
الاسرائيليه القريبه من الخط الاخضر وهذا
ما يعني بان ربما العمليات الاسرائيليه
باتت تتخذ خطوات متقدمه في تحويل هذه
البلدات الاسرائيليه القريبه من خط الخط
وقف اطلاق النار الى خط مواجهه وهذا ما
ابتعده او لم يعهده الاسرائيليون في هذه
البلدات في السابق حيث اصبحت هذه البلدات
على مرمى او تحت مرمى هذه الخلايا
الفلسطينيه التي باتت توجه نيرانها باتجاه
هذه البلدات الاسرائيليه في هذا السياق
يشير ايضا الى ان قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي واصلت هذه الليله عمليات الدعم
وقامت في عمليه دهن واسعه الى مخيم نور ش
الواقع الى الشرقي من مدينه طولكرم في هذه
العمليه ايضا اصيب جندي اسرائيلي بجروح
متوسطه وهو من احدث المختاره في عمليه
اطلاق نار وقعت في المكان لكن الجندي كما
افاد جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
اصيب بشظيه عبوه الناسفه القيت باتجاه
القوه العسكريه التي كانت تعمل على اعتقال
مطلوبين لاجهزه الامن الاسرائيليه في تلك
المنطقه كما ان قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
قامت في عمليات دهن واعتقال في مناطق
متعدده في الضفه الغربيه